always good to see you Vaughn now this
is a different kind of cold than Denver
isn't it yes this is the real calm
Denver is this
what if what if they had a home-field
advantage and they had an open stadium
instead of a dome Stadium
I think it would be advantage for
anybody only you can really yeah you
can't really prepare you know for the
code is just cold but Lambeau
that's a home-field advantage for the
Packers I mean a steel cold for the
Packers - they still call with a Packers
- I mean they play in it but you can you
can never get used to like the altitude
or you know how cold it is coldest
weather you ever played in coldest game
Coda's game would have to be I played in
two Co games we played in New England
one year it was it was crazy code and we
were up by 24 points and they came back
and then the playoff game versus the
Ravens my and 2012 what's that feeling
like on defense when you're up big on
Brady and you just see that it's coming
I mean when you're a big on Brady you
never really like you know you never let
the guard down anyway you know you're
only three touchdowns away and they
score one nice - and we thought in this
session now we're down we're only about
one touchdown unless anybody's game with
Tom Brady Tony Romo said this on the
broadcast I think against Jacksonville
he said never
Brady's never throwing where his eyes
start have you heard that no because
he's gonna look over here and he's not
gonna throw over there but the defense
still buys into that he could throw over
there how was that possible Vaughn he's
just the wizard it's just the wizard
I've been plays were you looking to the
right and you know guys steal flow to
the left and he throws it right so it's
he just has that effect on the defense
is it weird to chase a guy like that who
not very fast
I mean you should get him yeah right I
mean he he is like he has eyes on the
rush he has one eye on the rush and he
has one eye down the field and you know
he's he's he's trying to avoid the
tackle before guys even get to him
he's like he has Iona rushing his
identifiy or at all time do you talk to
him no I don't talk to probably like you
know a couple of times do I you know
during like a timeout or something I
talk to me well the games we wanted to
maybe I should talk to the morning game
but do you talk to anybody no I don't
talk to anybody I was talking them last
week I was talking to jaylen Ramsey at
the Pro Bowl yeah about how to trash
talk
no you don't know how to trash talk I
mean I really don't I really don't you
trashed on somebody what do you try to
talk somebody and they get you a next
play
you know then would you give your von
Miller I mean chances are you're gonna
probably have a better ratio of success
against them then they're gonna have
against you but linemen do guys say
stuff to you no I mean no we just we
just stare at each other I listen to the
guys on defense what did Jalen Ramsay
teach you about trash-talking Jalen was
like man you should talk trash and if
they gives you you just say it's a fluke
because that's you just call it a fluke
and you long back up again and then you
beat him on an ex play but I just you
know I'm so focused and on the play
before and then the the potential play
after that I like to really like you
know forecast I really like to you know
get in tomorrow at the office I just
don't like talking to him yeah but what
if somebody the lineman holds you off
you long to hold me um I mean I hope the
rest you know but you don't say anything
to him like you guys you got a cheap I
probably get here that's a given
I'm gonna get every game every game
every play probably is yeah most likely
what if we just made holding legal if
you may hold in if you may hold an eagle
it was still looking like the same
nobody how about this I make I make
lineman wear mittens so how about that
yeah like like little boxing gloves
where you can't really get to your hands
around somebody's house it but you have
to wear it too so for the game to be
fair they have to hold me so oh it is a
four afford to be fair they have so I
wouldn't change it yes I should what is
that moment like right before you hit
somebody and they don't know you're
hitting them so that quarterback and you
get him on the blind side
you know what it's that the moment right
before you hit a quarterback some
quarterbacks can feel that and they
could just move slightly to get out of
the way or you know Russell Wilson and
in the Pro Bowl game switches to the
left hand throw it you know I still a
little bit of time there so you really
don't have the quarterback until you
have them and your hands and then even
then when you have them in the hands you
gotta make sure you get the ball out
because they can steal you know flip the
ball but would you rather rush the
passer so you're facing the the
quarterback sees you or the other way
around where they'll blindside you know
you when you get to when you get close
to the quarry but you have to slow down
anyway if you run at full speed it's a
lot of Corbin's they can spin out and do
all type of crazy stuff so when you get
close to them you want to slow down and
make sure you make the tackle
he's a von Miller do you know how many
sacks you have in your career I think
he's worth eighty three and a half yeah
that's right that's right
yeah Dan Marino knew all his stats too I
mean that's a important stat for me you
know so you got okay what what is a Hall
of Fame's sack total now Oh 130 so you
got to get to 130 de Morgan's got 134
Marcus is in for sure and there's some
guys under DeMarcus that I probably got
ser Hall of Fame but you need 130 no I
mean I plan on you know Tina year for 20
years that's 200 right there that's the
record so but you also were Super Bowl
MVP mm-hmm so that's gonna help as well
you may not need a hundred and thirty
you do I'm gonna see DeMarcus let me see
the Marcus in that I need this I guess
he's underrated the mark is worth yes
yeah wait do you think he's overrated
no I mean I think I think the way people
look at him is exactly where he's
somebody no I I don't I think if you ask
people how many sacks does he have in
his career people wouldn't have any idea
I mean he has 130
here's 135 and it was about 3 years in
there where he wasn't really the
demarcus way that everybody looked at
him again so everybody got you know 15
or 20 SEC's those years it might have
been 170 what do you think is possible
for Saxum season probably 24 and who who
do you think could get that von miller
oh really yeah von Miller yeah we need
to do is get you just went third person
I mean yes I mean all we need to do is
just you know we got Shane reading other
sachet where it's gonna be good
ya know if Shane WA if Shane ray can get
about 15 secs that'll help you gotta
help everybody else all right let me ask
you about do you think the Broncos tried
to trade for Alex Smith I don't think
but that doesn't mean Elway didn't reach
out to say hey but Eve what's it gonna
take from Andy Reid and that's the way
so Elway calls your Andy Reid a and II
just uh you know I know mahomes your
future kind of could use a good
quarterback Andy Reid yeah you know what
I'm gonna hold on to Alex you know I
think I'm a hoarder Alex for you know
let him play out through his contract we
know that that's not true you're not
gonna you got my home he's there I'm
gonna keep them keep them going I
wouldn't let a quarterback like you know
Alex come to a team with us you know and
that's really you know every team has
needs but the quarterback is a knee
force and that could totally change our
team around so if I'm Andy Reid I
wouldn't give us a kirk cousins walked
in right now what would you say to him I
mean I've been talking to Kurt for the
longest so yeah but what do you been
saying I got a mix on the show no no but
I'm just saying if he walked in what
would you say I'm surprised when you
recruit him no I play cool no you know
you got a he he knows he knows exactly
how I feel about Carrie cousins and what
he would mean to our team and what he
would mean to a lot of teams you know
he's that he's the hot quarterback on
the morning you had a conversation you
said hey you know
yeah we need goofing around now we need
Kerry I would like to have Kurt you know
we have we have you know a great quarter
of a Chanel um Kurt could take us over
the edge I mean but that's the National
Football League is it's a lot of teams
they need it's a lot of teams that need
a great quarterback
and whatever team he is a would be a
different team and then he doesn't have
to worry about you sacking here you
don't have to worry about right you know
I do worry about yeah I almost had him
three times when we played them so he
didn't they have to you know worry about
it all yeah and you can't hit him in
practice either no no I can't do nothing
is there a quarterback who doesn't like
you that you know does it like you and I
know like no that grin tells me there
had to be somebody everybody's
everybody's always cool and friendly I
like the thing that I'm quarterback like
in my past life I was a quick listen
when I get around quarterbacks it just
feels like normal quarterback talk do
you so you feel like you have to play
the position to understand the position
no I just got to be normal just regular
yeah
what's your what's your eyesight my
eyesight is terribly bad it's negative
501 I 475 and you wear contacts during
the game contacts during the game
practice so I because I thought at first
when you wore the glasses they were like
costume yes yes Dwyane Wade remember
when Dwyane Wade had no lenses anyone
whose glasses yeah I mean that's the
craziest like people like you and me we
got bad on yeah but as as a glasses
where I was offended by that like I have
to wear these things I mean it's it's
crazy when you see when you see guys
this is where costume is like you know
you wouldn't see guys just get a
wheelchair
I love the helmet you brought so explain
the Microsoft's create change program
that you came in to talk about my vision
is my foundation my eyesight is terrible
I'm coming to the National Football
League I tried to find a way that I
could put my fingerprint on things they
actually give back I didn't want to just
do a football camp or you know anything
like they don't want to do something
that was 100 percent Vaughn started
Laurens vision and we partnered with
Microsoft create a change program and we
designed this helmet right here and you
got an eye chart on their chart only if
you'll hold it up and show it to the
camera there if we designed this helmet
in and fans can also design a helmet too
you can go
to the Microsoft Store design a helmet
for a chance to win a trip to Super Bowl
53 that's that's a very cool helmet
there yeah it's cool Picasso got me
right yeah but you did the designing
there no because I did it I helped duel
I gave him like a little it's a surface
Todd comm slash NFL to check out bonds a
create change video and how you can win
tickets to Super Bowl 53 that'll be in
Atlanta
I also saw your dancing at the Pro Bowl
mm-hmm how'd you rate that dancing
actually new dance when you get a strip
sack for the game I mean you can do
whatever you know 40 can you imitate
Vaughn's dance there I mean you love Von
Miller let's see let's see what you got
here because yep fritzy came in he said
y'all you got it we got to play this
when Von Miller comes in I said I do all
right let me see do we have the video
fritzy okay they have it here let me see
if they can they can play that back
that's pretty good there and fritzy did
you pull groin there on that I made
something something fell something came
loose I'll try to make it to work
tomorrow see he's uh Von Miller it's
bonds create change video go to surface
dot-com slash NFL great to see you we
always appreciate you stopping by every
Super Bowl and maybe one of these Super
Bowls you won't stop by because you'll
be back playing in it all right Von
Miller for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]